rice is such a staple ingredient and yet
so many people fear it so many people
say i don't know how to make it it gets
too sticky it gets burnt how do you make
the perfect rice we're here to tell you
there's a few really simple tips and
tricks to get that perfect fluffy great
consistency the two most important
things to keep in mind when making rice
are timing and ratios if you cook it too
short it can be hard and if you cook it
for too long it can just be gummy and
mushy no one wants that in regards to
ratios if you have too much water you
can just have really wet rice and if you
don't have enough you can burn your rice
for long grain white rice you want one
cup of rice to two cups of water for
short grain white rice you want one cup
of rice to one and a quarter cups water
for brown rice you want one cup of rice
to one and three quarter cups water for
whatever type of rice you're making
you're going to follow a similar process
one tip to help you make the best rice
ever is to rinse your rice before
cooking it rinsing rice helps remove any
extra starch if you're short on time you
can skip this step but it's a foolproof
way to help you get really fluffy
beautiful rice some people rinse the
rice until the water runs clear a good
method to go by is just rinsing it three
times first i'm going to add the rice
and the water and a pinch of salt
totally optional but it'll give it some
extra flavor and bring it to a boil over
high heat once the water begins to boil
give it a stir put the lid on and turn
the heat down to simmer which is the
lowest heat there is for long grain
white rice you want to cook it for 18
minutes on simmer for short grain white
rice you want to simmer for 15 minutes
brown rice is a bit longer you want to
simmer it for 45 minutes one really
important thing to note is to not remove
the lid as you're cooking it you're
steaming the rice and you don't want to
let the hot air escape just let it be
trust the timing and it'll come out
perfectly
pro tip once you remove the pot from the
heat let it steam for an additional five
to ten minutes with the lid on and
that's another way to ensure you get
really fluffy beautifully cooked rice
again if you're short on time you can
skip this step but we're trying to get
you the best rice possible it's worth
the extra 5 to 10 minutes to get really
fluffy rice
long grain white rice is perhaps the
most common rice at least in america you
can use it for side dishes pilaf salads
or just on its own with a protein short
grain white rice is typically used for
sushi puddings paella risotto and sticky
rice brown rice is considered to be a
healthier option than white rice it has
more fiber iron and vitamin b
so white rice is actually brown rice
with the bran and germ stripped away so
you're losing some of those nutrients
when you're choosing white rice and
while it does take longer to make it's a
bit earthier nuttier if you do it
correctly you can actually get a really
nice result
now that you know how to make a really
simple pot of rice we're going to show
you how to upgrade it with a few super
simple tips and tricks so first add
olive oil over high heat in the pan next
step add shallots or you can swap this
out with any other allium you could use
onions scallions garlic anything that's
going to give it a bit of flavor cook
the shallots for 30 seconds to a minute
until it's aromatic and golden brown
then add the rice give that a stir to
make sure that it's fully coated with
the shallots and the olive oil you only
need to do this for about 30 seconds so
right now you're just toasting the rice
that's a really easy way to add some
extra nutty flavor then add a splash of
white wine this is totally optional the
alcohol burns off and it's just a really
nice way again to add flavor you can
also swap water for stock vegetable
stock chicken beef whatever you want to
use and again a pinch of salt will go a
long way so from here the process is the
same you'll get a really flavorful
result without spending too much extra
time the thing is you can mix and match
with what you want to add to upgrade
your rice it's a really easy way to
trick your friends into thinking you're
extra fancy it's true they're gonna love
it if you're someone who makes rice all
the time it might be worth investing in
a rice cooker rice cookers are super
easy to use they're less fussy
everything's marked out for you in terms
of proportions it's a foolproof way of
getting a consistently perfect batch of
rice every time the first steps to
becoming a better cook are mastering the
basics rice is such a staple dish and if
you can master it it'll just make you a
better cook it really doesn't have to be
scary and it doesn't have to be boring
either if you just pay attention to
timing and ratios and add a few flavor
boosters you can have the best rice ever
tune in next week to tasty 101 we're
making
what are we making the ultimate
chocolate cake
damn that's a great reason tune in
[Music]